after a gamma bomb exploded in his face
Bruce Banner gained incredible powers
that turned him into a colossal green
superhero curse for serious self control
issues and a major case of self-loathing
Hulk became one of the most intriguing
characters and Marvel's pantheon and in
the past 50 years Marvel has adapted the
emeraude Avenger countless times for the
screen where do all those Hulk's rank
here are the highs and lows of his
smashing career sir
kisara seems horrible travis willingham
in Super Hero Squad in 2009 the Super
Hero Squad show featured adaptations of
classic Marvel storylines a set in Super
Hero City overseen by Mayor Stan Lee of
course travis willingham provided the
voice of the show's Hulk
and although the green Goliath was a
regular player the series kept the story
simple Holcomb mostly made juvenile jabs
at his teammates and pulverized stuff
and while the super fun gags are
entertaining enough for an adult
audience the real goal of the series was
almost certainly selling toys to
impressionable children don't be scared
read scary Eric Bana and Hulk you
probably know angley's 2003 film for
this beautifully shot sequence which
follows Hulk as he hops from mountaintop
to mountaintop in the ruddy desert sadly
Lee's entry was an otherwise clunky
affair full of tacked-on nonsense like a
CGI brawl between old purple pants and
some monster dogs and while Eric banners
performance of a classic right down to
that signature line yeah
we can't say the same for the CGI a
decade later this whole commits dated
and cumbersome
Ron Perlman and the Marvel action our
technically won Perlman only played the
Hulk in two episodes of the Marvel
action hour but come on it's Ron friggin
Perlman we'd never leave him off his
list Pearlman really threw himself into
the role but since his legacy as the
Hulk is hampered by his limited screen
time most people will remember him for
the way he looks in red not green excuse
me
Fred tatasciore in agents of smash in
2013 the Hulk got his very own spin-off
in the animated series agents of smash
which stands for the Supreme Military
agency of superhumans because of course
it does his team of bruises included
she-hulk his hokey son Skaar the Red
Hulk and Rick Jones as his
gamma-irradiated alter ego a bomb the
series was short-lived but showcased
some solid hulk action and a dollop of
personal development plus the voice
talents of actor Fred tatasciore with
Norton and The Incredible Hulk five
years after the characters first
big-screen adventure the franchise
rebooted itself of the Incredible Hulk
the movie that introduced the character
to the still new Marvel Cinematic
Universe Edward Norton gave audiences a
new answer Bruce Banner and even the
motion captured CG hawk looks good
unfortunately creative tensions but we
marvel the Norton who we vote the
scripts forced the actor to make his own
Hulk size to exit from the franchise
[Music]
Michael Bell and Bob holes and the
Incredible Hulk and the amazing
spider-man in 1982 spider-man and his
amazing friends merged with the
Incredible Hulk to create an 80s Power
Hour Michael Bell voice Bruce Banner
or Bob Holtz who also voiced the grape
ape provided the Hulk's nose like its
predecessors this theory centered on
banners episodic quest to cure himself
in a story that remains faithful to the
hoax bomb dolt origins the series also
saw Hulk take on Quasimodo in an epic
feud that Marvel later adapted into his
own comic some of the plots were
half-baked
and the animation could be choppy but
powered by 80s nostalgia this super
friend the lands pretty close to the top
Neal McDonough and Lou Ferrigno in the
Incredible Hulk
in 1996 Marvel green letters animated
series for the satisfaction of Hulk fans
everywhere neal mcdonough voice to
banner while Lou Ferrigno who had
already played the Green Giant in the
live-action 70 series came full circle
as the voice of the Hulk stop calling me
hope I'm a person okay
this show was pretty solid and there
wasn't just a smash Athan particularly
during a downbeat first season when
banner and Hulk both whose self-loathing
but the next season through too many
additional Hulk's into the mix and
overburden the dialogue with one-liners
leaving the series with a mere two
season lifespan poor souls and Max
Ferguson and the Marvel Super Heroes
let's go back in time to 1966 when the
Marvel Super Heroes explored The
Adventures of iron man named ER Thor and
of course the Hulk poor souls and the
Max Ferguson lent their voices to Bruce
Banner and the Hulk and each mini
episode tackled one of his stories the
animation studio used an old-school
technique called the rogue Rafi to
capture the original spirit of Marvel's
greenest Guardian the visuals aren't
impressive by modern day standards but
it still got plenty of vintage charm
Oh bill bixby
and Lou Ferrigno and The Incredible Hulk
starring a big spheres David Banner and
Ferrigno as the Hulk CBS's The
Incredible Hulk delivered four seasons
of panther shredding action between 1978
and 1982 the series worked over the
source material changing banners first
the name and completely ignoring his
usual cast of sidekicks instead intrepid
reporter Jack McGee trailed banner on
his cross-country quest for a cure the
stunts effects and formulaic plots might
be corny by today's standards but hopes
writers treated banner and displayed
with respect and the shows that inspires
the many hoaxes who were followed in
Liu's chalky green footsteps after CBS
canceled the series in 1982 NBC snatched
up the rights under vive de banner and
his big green alter ego in three follow
up TV movies which included Stan Lee's
first live-action cameo though obviously
not his last
Mark Ruffalo and the Avengers Mark
Ruffalo sets the standard for modern era
hulks with this performances and the
Avengers and age of Ultron which
perfectly suit the tongue-in-cheek tone
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe through
this banner doesn't get much love time
or even a proper origin story but his
intellectual sparring with Tony Stark
proves he's got some serious brains and
while alien invasions and robot
overlords don't leave much room for a
personal life those interlude with Black
Widow proved that he can smash walls and
break hearts sadly we're still waiting
on a proper MCU Solar adventure for
Ruffalo's take on the big green guy but
for now he's a valuable team member and
the man behind many primo cinematic
moments from the Hulkbuster fight in
Avengers 2 to the thrashing Loki needs
and deserves - revealing the one weird
trick - hulking out on command that's my
secret cash
I'm always in thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]